Hello, how are you? Natalia Lancelot greets you,
and regarding today's newscast, it's
nothing in Spanish. Former
Las Vegas Raiders player Henry Brooke
Setter appeared in front of the judge this
morning after skipping a
mandatory alcohol test last week.
Rocks  He must take this test four
times a day as part of his
obligations after the accident in which
23-year-old Tina Pintor died. Prosecutors
said that he was driving under the
influence of toxic substances in addition
to going more than 150 miles per hour
prior to the Reimond crash.  boulevard
in early november changing the
subject las vegas metropolitan police
are investigating a
murder east of the valley this happened
shortly after 1 30 in the morning
inside an apartment complex
located on sahara a woman has come crossing
cornelis boulevard  in her
twenties she was shot and died during a
fight with a man authorities
believe it was a case of violence
domestic and mccarran airport is
preparing for one of the
busiest weekends of the year about 2
million people will travel during the week
it is estimated that tuesday will be the
busiest day in most
airports flights are departing and landing
on time here in mccartney they also
advise to be at the
establishment well in advance to avoid
any unforeseen and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have
sunny days for this week with
temperatures around 60 degrees they
will rise a little by Tuesday we will have
some breezes for the day
Thanksgiving with the maximum in 63 beautiful
day Natalia Lanzelotti greets you and this was
your brief informative of and we now in
Spanish